100 days in office at the time
some told us that it couldn't be done it
was awfully ambitious but we did it in
58 days
because of the incredible staff i have
and so i set a second goal
to deliver 200 million shots in my first
100 days in office
the goal unmatched in the world or in
prior mass vaccination efforts in
american history
when tomorrow's vaccine and vaccination
numbers come
out we'll show that today
we did it today we hit 200 million
shots and the 92nd day in office
200 million shots in 100 days
in under 100 days actually it's an
incredible achievement for the nation
and here's the context
you know at the pace we're moving when i
took office it would have taken us more
than 220 days
almost seven months seven and a half
months to reach 200 million shots
instead of marking this milestone in
april we would not have
seen it until early september at the
earliest
some experts say that our the rapid
vaccination effort has already saved
tens of thousands of american lives
we'll never know exactly but we know it
saved lives
that would have otherwise been lost i'm
proud of the work my administration has
done to get americans vaccinated
but more than that i'm proud of the
american people
the volunteers who showed up to staff
vaccination sites in their neighborhoods
drove senior citizens to get their shots
fema the military the national guard
state and local health departments
and providers running sites safely and
efficiently
retired health care workers coming back
to give life-saving shots
to people in their communities this is
an american achievement
a powerful demonstration of unity and
resolve
what unity will do for us and a reminder
of what we're going to accomplish when
we pull together as one people
to a common goal now that we've reached
this milestone
we're entering in a new phase of our
vaccination effort
as of monday in my direction with the
support of 50 governors
democrats and republicans alike everyone
over the age of 16
will be eligible to get vaccinated
the first three months of our
vaccination program ferguson
focused on targeting vaccines to
specific
high-risk groups now our objective is to
reach
everyone everyone over the age of 16 in
america
wherever you live whatever your
circumstances
if you are 16 or older you are now
eligible for a free
covert vaccine shot and we have the
vaccine
to deliver we head into this next phase
it's important for us to look at where
we stand
after three months of targeting
vaccinations largely to health care
workers
front-line workers and people with
high-risk conditions
nursing homes nursing home residents and
seniors
the progress we've made has been
stunning
let me point out a few achievements
first
as of this past sunday more than 50
percent of adult americans
have had at least one vaccine shot
we still have a long way to go but
that's an important
marker of progress when it comes to our
target groups
the largest groups we focused on in
these past
92 days have been seniors americans aged
65 and
older they account for 80 percent of all
the cova
deaths before we started vaccinating
when i took office 8 of the people over
65
had received their first shot i'm
pleased to announce that by tomorrow
that total will exceed 80 percent of the
people over the age of 65.
80 of american seniors of all races
religions political views will have had
at least
one shot it'll be another month or so
before we see the full benefits of this
effort
as many seniors still need the second
shot plus the two weeks to gain that
protection after the second shot
but already we've seen a dramatic
decline in deaths among people over the
age of 65
an 80 reduction in deaths of people over
the age of 65.
still far too many lives lost
but also a lot of lives saved in the
weeks ahead
as more seniors reach full vaccination
that number of lives loss will continue
to decrease
you know we've made great progress with
another target group
as well educators school staff
bus drivers and child care workers
back in february when many of our
schools were
fully or partially closed the center for
disease control
and prevention the cdc issued guidelines
to help reopen our schools safely
then in march congress approved the
american rescue plan to fund
the safe reopening of our schools one
thing is clear
many educators are understandably
anxious about going back to a classroom
without being vaccinated
and many parents were understandably
nervous about sending their kids back as
well
so on march the second i launched a
program directing all states to make
educators school staff school bus
drivers
child care workers eligible for
vaccination in
every state so the school and child care
centers could open
with a peace of mind within a month
80 percent had received at least one
shot
and schools and child care centers all
over the country are reopening
now to be clear we still have some work
to do with our target groups
we've made remarkable progress and as we
continue
as i said the time is now to open up a
new phase of this
historic vaccination effort to put it
simply
if you've been waiting for your turn
wait no
longer now is the time for everyone over
16 years of age to get vaccinated
unlike the target groups where we've
made such great progress
the broad swath of american adults still
remain largely unvaccinated
in a number of states they weren't
eligible for the vaccination until this
week
too many younger americans may still
think they don't need to get vaccinated
so let me explain two reasons why we
need everyone over 16 years of age
in america to get vaccinated
and share what we're going to do to
encourage it
the first reason quite simply is to keep
you from getting very sick
or dying hundreds of americans are still
dying from covet every day
the data could not be clear at this
point
if you are fully vaccinated two weeks
beyond your last shot you are nearly 100
percent protected against
death from covet no matter what your age
no matter what your health history until
you are fully vaccinated you are still
vulnerable the vaccine can save your
life
the second reason to get vaccinated is
to protect your community
your family your friends and your
neighbors black schemes can save
your own life but they can also save
your grandmother's life
your you know your co-worker's life the
grocery store clerk
or the delivery person helping you and
your neighbors get through the crisis
now that's why you should get vaccinated
let me talk about how we're making it
easier for you to be able to get
vaccinated
first there are some steps i announced
previously
that are hitting the ground this week
ninety percent of the american people
now live within five miles of a place
where they can get a shot
and under our federal vaccination
program shots will be available
at nearly 40 000 pharmacies
coast to coast and if you can go into a
busy
to buy your shampoo or toothpaste
you can stop and get vaccinated the
vaccine is free
it's convenient and it's increasingly
available
but i know that isn't enough as you move
into the vaccination campaign focused on
working age adults
one concern i've heard from so many
americans is that
they can't afford to take the time off
to get vaccinated
or lose a day's work because they have
feelings slightly under the weather
after they're shot
so today i'm announcing a program to
address that issue nationwide
i'm calling on every employer large and
small
in every state to give employees the
time
off they need with pay to get vaccinated
and anytime they need with pay to
recover
if they're feeling under the weather
after the shot
no working american should lose a single
dollar from their paycheck
because they chose to fulfill their
patriotic duty of getting vaccinated
we're already seeing employers large and
small stepping up to meet this historic
moment
the grocery store krugers offered
employees 100
to get vaccinated it helped push the
vaccination rates
from 50 percent to 75 among their
associates
patty young owns a hair salon in
springfield ohio
she's also dedicated to getting her
customers and employers vaccine
employees vaccinated
that when they leave the saloon the
receptionist
the saloon the salon they may be going
to a saloon i don't know
but when they read when they leave the
salon the receptionist
helps sign you and your family up to get
a covert vaccine
and where to get it they've scheduled
more than 200 shots so far
businesses employers like patty should
be supported
for doing the right thing so to make
sure this policy comes at
no cost to small or medium-sized
businesses
with fewer than 500 employees they are
the irs is posting instructions for how
employers
can get reimbursed for the cost of
providing paid leave for their employees
to get vaccinated and recover from the
side effects that they have in it
that reimbursement which comes through a
tax payment
is thanks to the program i launched in
the american rescue plan
so again every employee
should get paid leave to get a shot
and businesses should know that they can
provide it without
a hit to their bottom line there's no
excuse for not getting it done
in the weeks ahead i'll have more to say
about
other new developments in our vaccine
program
we'll also continue moving aggressively
to build our
progress build on our progress and race
to the finish line here
but let me close with this back on march
11th
i outlined a vision of what america
could look like by
the fourth of july an america
that was much closer to normal life that
we left behind more than a year ago
we remain on track for that goal
in the weeks since then more than 120
million shots have been given since i
announced the july 4th
more of our kids are back in school and
after a long and painful year more
grandparents are able to hug their
grandkids again
it's great progress but if we let up now
and stop being vigilant this virus will
erase the progress we've already
achieved
the sacrifices we've made the lives that
been put on hold
the loved ones who've been taken from us
the time we're never going to get back
to celebrate our independence
from this virus on july 4th with family
and friends in small groups
we still have more to do in the months
of may
and june we all need to mask up
until the number of cases goes down
until everyone has a chance to get their
shot
to americans 16 years and older
it's your turn now now
so go get your vaccine before the end of
may
we can do this and we'll do this as long
as we don't
let up so thank you all very much
as i said a long time ago we're going to
beat this
as long as we do it together and i want
to again thank
my kova team i want to thank the vice
president i want to thank jeff science
behind me and the entire kova team
for putting this together may god
protect
truth god bless you all thank you thank
you
yet but i and you asked about what about
abroad helping abroad
we're in the process of doing that we've
done a little bit of that already
we're looking at what is going to be
done
with some of the vaccines that we are
not
using we have to make sure they are
safe to be sent and we hope to be able
to be of some
help and value to uh countries around
the world we've
talked to our neighbors a matter of fact
a fellow who's working really hard
to take care of his country and deal
with this i was on the phone with for
about half an hour today and the prime
minister of canada
we helped a little bit there we're going
to try to help some more but there's
other countries as well that i'm
confident we can help including
in central america and uh so
but it's it's in process we don't have
enough to be confident to give senate
abroad now
but i i expect we're going to be able to
do that thank you